thank you
all right
thank you for joining me today i'm
adrian braganza tucker i am ex-mongodb
and that's very important
and today i'd like to talk to you about
data modeling for document databases so
who here has heard tabloid-esque types
of sentences like this document
databases are schema-less raise your
hand okay who thinks that's a bad thing
that they're schemerless
okay yeah be confident in your answer
yeah yep sometimes that can be right and
sometimes it's not necessarily a bad
thing but when we work with document
databases so like mongodb or cosmos tb
or documentdb both of which are actually
just based on top of mongodb
we kind of hear these types of tabloids
type of sentiments
so we get things like oh there's field
flexibility for all documents and that's
amazing or what data model right the
whole point of you wanting to use a
document database is that you're not
restricted by a very rigid schema you
want you don't know what that could be
at the very beginning when you are used
to working with relational databases
very much like how my background was
that's kind of the first thing that you
do right you very meticulously detail
out what your model is going to be and
then you build out the application
whereas with document databases most of
the time we kind of argue well you build
the application first and then you build
your data model along with it
but if there's anything that you get
from this presentation today it's that i
want you to take away that there that
there is a data model that while
flexibility is great in theory it is not
great in reality in reality all of the
data that we work with has some kind of
structure that's the whole reason why
it's important to us that's the whole
reason why it's meaningful in our
applications without that structure
without those relationships all of this
large amounts of data is essentially
useless to us unless we make sense of it
somehow
and so that's what i want to talk to you
about today how to develop a data model
for document databases either how to
refine the way that you build a data
model or to show you how to actually
build one if you've never heard of this
before
the goals of this session are to learn
how to create that data model in three
phases and then we'll apply that
methodology to a casino floor analytics
application because i'm based from las
vegas and i feel that will be a very
very different example for most of you
and then finally what i think is the
most important but i leave towards the
end so that you could think about it
after this presentation is to understand
what exactly we're modeling for
so
if there's anything you take away from
this it's that it is possible and it is
necessary for you to develop a data
model if you are using a document
database don't go along with the
tabloids don't just say oh yeah we'll
just throw some stuff in there throw
some fields in there will be great
because if you do that it's going to
impact your application's performance
very much like how the data model that
you create for a relational database or
an application that uses a relational
database it's going to affect your app
so as an example it's kind of hard to
read but the whole point here is
depending on the data model that you use
you can have someone of the raving
reviews of the document database that
you've uh used for your application
amazing performance we were able to do
this many requests per second
yada yada yada and then with that same
exact database you'll get reviews like
this of oh my gosh i'm only working with
a thousand records and it is so slow
what's going on what's wrong and most
likely the most common culprit of this
is they've taken their relational data
model
take all that data through it into some
document database and then wonder why
it's not working well the model is
different you model data differently in
different types of databases so you have
to
restructure your data accordingly
and so we'll get through the first part
how do you actually build a data model
in three phases
so there's a methodology here that's
quite iterative you can go through these
three phases over time and you may have
to go through them over and over again
as your data model evolves with your
application
so the very very first thing that you do
is you make sense of your workload
making sense of your workload means
gathering everything there is that you
could possibly want to know about your
data
through this discovery phase you're
going to find a lot of inputs as to
where you can get this kind of data
first and foremost is listing qualifying
and quantifying all of the operations
that are running through your
application what are the queries that
are running through your app what are
the ones that are there but are not
being used what are your most important
ones what are the amounts of those is it
two
tweets per hour is it this many requests
per second if you can get down to those
types of granular numbers the better you
are not only
do you have a good estimate if this is
the first time that you're starting out
but as you go through this methodology
over time you have a baseline that you
can
see where there are different
differentiations or deviations from what
your normal was like or from where you
first started so taking into account all
of these types of operations the reads
the rights everything that you have is a
very very good place to start
the next thing that can help you out are
production logs and statistics so if you
already have that tooling in place if
you have those kinds of metrics being
recorded these are very very good places
to look for that additional information
where are your spiky traffic loads what
quarters are you kind of dormant and
don't have as much uh traffic going
through where are your unexpected
traffic spikes happening do they occur
because of something that was deployed
or was it because of a timely or
seasonal type of issue these are other
good things to keep in mind when you
kind of lay out that baseline of where
your application is today especially if
you're starting out and creating your
data model
next current and predicted scenarios so
kind of hand-in-hand with those
production logs and statistics you kind
of ask yourself what is our normal
traffic like what is our normal expected
workload and then you have some
predicted scenarios where let's say if
you are typical examples an e-commerce
application and you have some sort of
big holiday sale that you have more
traffic than you're used to those are
some sort of predicted scenarios that
you can estimate and know that you have
to either
deploy out more resources to help
accommodate that or even scale back once
you're done and finished with that
and then finally it's always good to
collaborate with the domain expert so as
developers as someone who's working in
the weeds most of the time sometimes we
kind of forget about the bigger picture
what are the other scenarios that we're
forgetting what are the other things
that are part of our application that we
may not be privy to because we're so
stuck on this feature or we've been
fixing this production fire for the last
two weeks as we start to add more people
into the conversation you always get
valuable insight that you may not always
have if you are very much down in the
weeds of your application
so we take all of these inputs we gather
everything there is possibly to know
about our data and what it is how it
processes through our application and
that feeds into some very very important
outputs the outputs you get from this
phase are number one the operations that
are running number two all the different
queries that are running in your
application
the data sizes that you are working with
both actual and estimated
indexes that you have or indices however
you want to say it and the ones that
you're missing more importantly
and all the assumptions that you have
built in so far to your application
once you have all of these outputs
you're going to be ready for the next
phase
and that next phase is to now map out
and identify those relationships
so
in this phase there's two things that
you do you first quantify and identify
what those relationships are and then
you decide do you link or do you embed
all of the relationships that you find
so who here has seen this type of
notation
one to one one to many many too many
that's good i would hope so
so yes if you come from a relational
background we're pretty familiar with
this right crow fits notation denoting
which entities have one-to-one
relationships one too many many too many
and it's the same with the document
database so that part doesn't change
those types of relationships still occur
when you work with data in a document
database
one thing that we did find however is
now that we're aggregating so much more
data and capturing way larger amounts
sometimes the one-to-many relationship
doesn't accurately capture that type of
relationship so we've actually added a
new one called one to zillions
and so if you think about time series
data or if you think about anything
where you're having thousands of
requests per second that amount of data
would probably qualify for a
relationship like this and so you can
see with the crow foot notation here
that the little difference here is that
we've added a couple extra lines there
that says there's a lot there's a lot on
the many side
and when we denote this notation numeral
wise what we would find here is you
would most likely want to add the
minimum which is usually zero or one
the likely amount which is the most
important number here and that's what's
your normal expected amount for this
particular relationship on the mini side
and then the maximum so that could be in
the millions the billions the zillions
whatever that is
a good example of this is actually
twitter followers right so most people
they will have at least 0 or one as a
minimum follower most people will have
around a few hundred and then for you
know the celebrities or people who are
super famous uh they'll have maybe in
the hundreds of millions of followers
so we've quantified the relationships we
found what the most important entities
are we found what relationships relate
to those entities and now we have to
decide which can be a somewhat long
process is do we link or do we embed
how many hairs like what's linking and
what's embedding
yeah that's that was me too i'm like
what is that and good thing is it's very
very self-explanatory
especially if you come from a relational
database background you already know one
of them
so linking what is linking let's say we
have a sample document here this is
holding a bunch of casinos and in this
particular document we hold some basic
information about the casino we have an
identifier we have the name of the
casino nicknames of what that casino
could be called the year that it opened
and then right here is where we link
owner with some sort of identifier
so linking just means very much like a
foreign key relationship we get some
additional information that may be
stored in this case we're storing it in
a different document and possible and of
course a different uh collection which
that would be an akin to a table so here
for owner we would identify that by the
identifier 3 here and that information
holds the owner information so that is
linking linking is very very similar to
foreign key relationships we store that
data somewhere else and we link to it in
the parent document
embedding on the other hand is just
taking the most important information or
the information that we usually query
together and we take it and embed it
into the parent document so here and uh
we find that let's say when we're
querying for casinos
we find that we're always looking for
the name of the owner the headquarters
and the the year that it was founded it
would be a good start to kind of take
that information and put it into the
parent document
and that's embedding
so these are very generalized guidelines
as to what you want to do whether to
link or whether to embed depending on
the type of relationship this is not a
framework where you're like is it a
one-to-one relationship okay we're gonna
link or embed it's not like that these
are general guidelines but for the most
part we want to encourage embedding in
the document because that goes for a
more simple data model and embedding
most things is probably what you'll need
so as you'll see here for one-to-one
one-to-many and even many-to-many
relationships if you do embed
information in your parent document you
will get a single read because if you do
it
the way that it is intended that single
read will encompass all the information
that you are accessing via the query you
have so that's one of the tenants of
document databases is any data that is
accessed together should be stored
together and so that really
encourages embedding for most things
if you are getting into a more
complicated data model or you have a lot
of information or you are working with
one two zillions then linking in the
parent document is probably better
especially if you're getting to that
zillions range on the the many side
linking is going to be preferred because
if you embed all of that information in
that many documents that's also not the
greatest thing for your data model so of
course with linking you're going to get
a lot of smaller reads but you're going
to have
many reads and sometimes that's not
always bad sometimes your application
needs that and sometimes the
sacrifice that you make for having an
additional read is what your app needs
rather than having a very very fast read
so we've taken all of the information
that is part of our application we take
all of those inputs and the data about
our workload we've now mapped out what
the different entities are we've mapped
out what the relationships exist between
all of these
and actually at the end of this phase
you pretty much have a data model that
you can work with
the one thing that we encourage is that
for phase three which is applying design
patterns you most likely don't need to
get into that unless you absolutely need
it so
what when you are done with
phase two
we only encourage if you are starting to
see performance problems
or if you find that you have a
performance threshold that you are not
meeting then you kind of go into step
three or phase three because applying
design patterns prematurely is very much
like premature optimization you come out
with a data model that's a little bit
harder to understand a little bit harder
to iterate on and a little bit harder to
adapt so only when you need it do you go
into the design pattern veins
and so with that what are design
patterns
well it is a reusable structure to a
commonly recurring problem so if you've
ever read design patterns for computer
science in general right the gang of
four
or any other type of acronyms or things
like that it's the same type of concept
it's something that you want to reuse
when you're solving some particular
problem and in this case for data
modeling these are models that you can
adapt to your data model depending on
the data that you have that fit very
very common use cases that we've seen
so what design patterns are available
and i'm going to come here because it
might be difficult to see
remove just in case
yep
so
we have very many design patterns we're
going to go through a few that we'll
actually use in our example and here
we'll start with the polymorphic pattern
so the polymorphic pattern who here has
heard of the term polymorphic
okay so then you will understand what
polymorphic means in the case of these
design patterns all this means is that
there are a variety of documents that
can exist within the same collection so
we take our example here
we have
let's say a sports betting application
and we're having uh the list of all the
different athletes that are here so we
have the late great kobe bryant right
here
and we have some information about him
specifically because he played
basketball right so for basketball we
keep the number of nba championships
that he's been a part of if he's in the
hall of fame etc now for serena
we still keep the sport the athlete name
and the career earnings but for serena
she plays tennis so a lot of her
information is going to be slightly
different
so polymorphic pattern states that
because
serena plays tennis and because tennis
has a couple different types of events
serena's document can look like this
we'll have all of her typical
information
but we can also store the events that
she's a part of in this case tennis can
have both singles and doubles events uh
we have changed her particular document
to hold her events in an array in this
way and polymorphic is kind of the basis
for all most of the design patterns and
that just says that her document looking
like this can exist in the same
collection as kobe bryant's who may not
have those types of event uh information
in his document
so attribute pattern the next pattern
here
is very very useful for uh problems that
have a lot of documents with a lot of
similar fields but the ones that you're
actually querying is just a small subset
of those so
in this case let's say we are keeping
track of all the different movies and in
our application we want to search for
them by the release date the problem
with that is release dates are different
across all countries it's not a single
release date and so in our very very
naive data model we found that we have
placed a top level release date field
for every single one
the problem with this is that if we
store it in this way
we need to have indexes for every single
one of those release date fields so in
this case something like the attribute
pattern is actually very very helpful
because instead we can
change the document to look like this
so instead of having every release and
every location be a top level field we
have an array that we will be indexing
and because we know we're going to be
searching by the release date we'll have
the attribute be the date and the actual
location because we know it's different
for every location
so by having it in this way and storing
that particular attribute the attribute
that we want to search on our index can
be much much simpler we'll only have to
do it on this array here
that is possible including the sub
fields as part of that array and
the great thing here is that the queries
are also way simpler because now you
don't have to add every single index
that you may possibly need for all of
the top level release date fields
finally there is the document versioning
pattern so this is really good pattern
to use when you're faced with
maintaining a lot of previous versions
of documents but you still need access
to the most current version of your
document for your application so one
really really boring example but i try
to make it as fun as i can is insurance
so insurance when you start out with
insurance
you
open up and get a policy you have a
standard policy writer right and when
you start out you maybe have only a few
things that you need to ensure so bilbo
here has decided to get some insurance
and at the time that he opened this up
the only things he needed to ensure were
the elven sword
now with the document versioning pattern
this makes sense right this would be a
collection of current policies so every
person that has insurance with us would
have a document in the current policy
collection and that would be the most
current the most up-to-date uh status or
state of that insurance
however as bilbo goes on and travels on
and you know changes a few things let's
say now he has a one ring to ensure
that's very very important well we can
use the document versioning pattern to
now add that one ring to our current
policy and to keep track of the the old
state of insurance we would have a
different collection maybe one called
policy revisions and we would add a
document there that would hold the old
state or revision one of his insurance
so
in this way we now have the most current
state of his insurance we would always
be querying and targeting the current
policies collection for that uh
that information and then we would keep
the history by adding the different
revisions that do occur in a separate
collection so the of course the
the cons of this is that it doubles the
number of writes because we now have to
add a new document every time a revision
is made but keeping that in mind uh we
kind of apply this to not only where you
need to keep track of revisions but
where revisions are not so common so
that's why insurance is kind of a good
policy you don't change it that often
unless you're a very volatile lifestyle
and need to change your insurance very
often uh but yeah and then the one of
the biggest pros of this is that it's
very very easy to implement even in
existing systems because the way you
implement it is simply by adding a top
level field an identifier in this case
we simply used an increasing integer
here you can use a different type of way
to
determine which one is the the most
current state but as long as you target
the right collection and you target the
right revision then that's the way you
can apply the document versioning
pattern
one thing that i did not add in here
that is also very very common is
something called the schema versioning
pattern so in a very very similar
fashion you would have two types of
schemas so let's say you have a very
very different schema and you have
you're in the middle of a migration or
you added a feature and you wanted to
test something out the greatest thing
about this is using this same kind of
pattern where you denote which schema
version you're using you can have both
types of schemas exist in the same
collection and that's something that a
lot of people do when they migrate to
something else so instead of having com
you know full downtime and doing a full
migration over to the new schema even if
it's just a single field that you are
adding or removing uh you can have both
of those documents exist in the same
place and you can have them exist for a
while now obviously you have to adapt
your application to that you have to
make sure you are targeting the right
schema version in your application and
you have to make sure that you remove
the older documents or the documents
with the schema version you no longer
need so that you clean up your
collection and also reduce the data size
but that is one very very common way to
be able to have two different versions
of your documents exist
yes
say again
in the current collection uh this is so
if you needed to target specifically
that particular person and that most
current one then that's the easiest way
to find it you can also add an index via
the revision number and if you have
duplication across both the collections
it's an easier way to target it via that
index
so you could have it
you know in your question it is also
still logical to only have the revision
number in the policy revision document
but just for being thorough we add it to
the existing one that way when we do
duplicate and add that particular
document to the policy revisions
collection we already have that
particular revision
so you're correct in the current policy
one you don't have to have it you could
still target it because
again building that assumption that the
current policy collection is always the
current then yes you can
build that assumption in that any
document in that collection will be the
most current but in case that doesn't
happen something changes at least you
know that you have that particular field
that you could query on to make sure
that it is the most current one
and we actually have way more patterns
here right so we do not have time for
them and i'm actually thinking of
possibly just going into a talk of just
the design patterns but the ones that we
did go through were the polymorphic
which are really good for catalog and
content management use cases or single
view and mobile applications we have the
attribute pattern which are fairly same
use cases where we use them mostly and
then the document versioning pattern
which is also very very good for
personalization
and then the last one here schema
versioning as you can see which is
pretty good for any use case
all right so you've learned the
methodology you now know if you were to
leave everything shut down and that's
the end of this presentation you now
know how to actually do it but i find
that going through an example somewhat
solidifies that understanding so we'll
go through it now and we'll go through
it for a casino for analytics
application
so the first step in this phase is to
make sense of our workload
who here has been to a casino
or las vegas
okay
that's good it's a dizzying place right
it looks like this it is purposely built
so you have no idea what time it is you
don't know where you are you don't know
what's happening it's dark it's a little
not so much smoky anymore because
they've outlawed that but this is kind
of what it looks like and so for our
particular application we're going to
build one that looks into the slot
machines in particular we want to keep
track of all of these things all of i
think i've pointed them out yeah so
there's all kinds of different slot
machines right there's
one for your favorite tv show one for
your favorite movie like there's a slot
machine for everything
and in our application we want to keep
track of certain
analytics of our slot machines so that
can be the wind chance rates the
jackpots that are associated with it the
bonus structures depending on what type
of slot machine it is and so we'll go
through a quick example of how we would
possibly develop a data model for that
kind of application
so
when we make sense of our workload
we find that these are the most
important queries that we want to focus
on
so
first one total player game time so if
you have a membership card at most of
these casinos when you put that
membership card into the slot machine we
can tap into that right we know when you
put the card in we know when you take
the card out and that's a somewhat
accurate estimate of how long you spent
at that particular slot machine so that
is one of the most important rights that
we can have as part of our application
we have a few more reads that we can use
as part of our analytics so that's the
wind chance rate the anomalies and the
win rates and the top slot machines
played so for the wind chance rate
there's not much that we can do there
there's a nevada gaming commission that
kind of sets what those ranges can be
and you have very very slight creativity
where you can move those ranges but it's
kind of set by that board but we have
that information and that is a read that
we can see what the current range is
right now
anomalies and win rates so there's
analytics on table games but there's
also analytics on slot machines so if
you've ever seen ocean's 11 or any type
of casino movie any heist type of movie
there are a
crap ton of cameras there that help out
with this they measure your temperature
they measure the way that you walk they
measure
what you're looking at at the moment
they measure how quickly you get excited
and they have all types of ways to tell
if that win is genuine or if it's not if
you're cheating
and so we have a lot of access to that
information because most casinos have a
very very rigorous fraud detection
system
and then the top slot machines played so
we have some analysis on the slot
machine play time from that player card
mechanism that we have but we also have
replay conversions so in a similar
fashion you know some people have their
favorite slot machine or they're like
this is a hot one i'm gonna win it this
it's hot i feel it and they come back to
that and they keep pouring money into
that we can not only tell how long
they've played in that particular slot
machine but we know how many times
they've come back based again on how
many times they've put in their
membership card so we know the
top of slot machines that have been
played because we can aggregate which
ones have the most play time and which
ones have the most replay conversions
and then finally one of the last
important rights that we have are
jackpot increases so if you've ever seen
these slot machines where it's like a
network of slot machines maybe they're
in a round or a ring sometimes they span
across multiple casinos they have all
are they're all connected to a single
screen and it's a jackpot that currently
er continuously increases
and as people play the more that people
don't win the more the jackpot increases
and so those increases are something
that we can tap into
especially if they span across multiple
casinos
as the jackpot increases or when
somebody wins that final jackpot we
reset that jackpot
and
the new jackpot starts but what we are
tapping into is the continuous rights of
how many times the jackpot increases
so we've made sense of our workload this
is the more simplified version and we'll
get to why that is in a moment in our
third section but those are the most
important queries that we find those are
the ones that we need for our
application so we take that information
and now we need to map out which pieces
uh or which entities are the most
important and what types of
relationships exist between all of those
things
so
we find that as part of the information
that we have a lot of our information
actually falls within a one-to-many type
of relationship the only one that is
kind of different right here are the
slots and casinos because slots can only
ever physically be in a single spot in a
single location in a single casino so
that's the only one-to-one relationship
that we find everything else from slots
and the different type of bonuses that
we have to the casinos
or the jackpots and the slots and the
players and the memberships these are
the most important relationships and the
most important entities that we have
and now we apply the design patterns
so in this particular application this
is what our data model could look like
so for our slots
our document will look like this we want
to keep track of uh we have the type the
manufacturer the location that it's in
we want its serial number
bonuses etc and also a revision
our jackpots would look like this um
we would hold the current total of the
jackpots as well as the participating
slots
we have casinos that we have determined
to be a good place to hold the casino
information which we also added the top
slots uh the floor manager etc and we
also have the players which has their
membership information are they a high
roller and their contact information etc
so this is our
starting data model or actually the
ending data model that we have and we
found that these are the pieces or
entities that we found would make great
collections great
top-level collections to hold our data
so the first choice we've made in our
data model is denoted here so everything
you see here that's circled or bordered
in white are the things we've decided to
embed so for slots every time that we
query for information on slots we
usually need the bonus structure that is
associated with them so we may store
bonus information in a different
collection but we've also opted to embed
them in the parent slot documents
because of the way that we query them
in a similar fashion we also have the
participating slots in the jackpot
documents
we have the top slots for the casinos
that are embedded
and we have embedded both the membership
information as well as the contact
information for our players so all of
these decisions all of these embedded
pieces of information are purely because
we need that information whenever we
query it
okay that was my
phone so that's option number one
remember that's decision number one in
our data model we've embedded those
pieces
the next thing that we've decided to
apply is the document versioning pattern
so we have in our slot documents
very similarly to how we did the
insurance example right we do have
another revision identifier here because
slots go through a lot of different
changes some of them are being
decommissioned some of them are getting
maintenance on them so some of them have
the bonus structure or the wind chance
rate changing slightly so we want to
keep track of these particular pieces of
information for our slot machines
in the same way players also change all
the time maybe they had one really
really bad weekend in las vegas and
they're no longer a high roller we want
to keep track of that revision sometimes
they're not a member anymore at one
casino or the other we want to keep
track of that and then in a similar
fashion contact information changes not
too much but sometimes it does they get
a new cell phone they move so we want to
keep track of that information as well
for our players
next is the attribute pattern so this
applies particularly to the slots and in
this particular case it is because of
the bonuses so if you've ever seen
the different types of slot machines
there are slot machines that have
different games on it and that will feed
into our next um
uh
pattern here which is the polymorphic
pattern so
putting those two together the attribute
pattern of the bonuses and polymorphic
that shows
so we have polymorphic here that's about
to be shown so attribute pattern right
here is uh we are querying mostly on the
bonuses we want to know which bonuses
are doing the best which ones are
attracting more people to those
particular slot machines and with the
polymorphic pattern combined we may have
different types of slot documents that
exist within the slot collection so a
typical slot document would look like
this
this one could be for the one that i was
just talking about so in this case we
have some game bonuses that hold the
type of game the bonus type bonus
percentage so slim slot machines have
you may see these you can choose the
game that you want to play there's texas
hold'em there's jacks or better there's
blackjack there's all kinds of different
permutations of card games that you can
choose and depending on which one you
choose and depending what level you are
at are you in the penny slots are you on
the dollar slots and making a lot of
money you can choose the game there and
then those particular bonuses will also
change with that
and then a document can also look like
this so as i was mentioning there are
probably i would bet
half of
half of my salary to say that there are
no more mechanical slot machines
left in las vegas so if you've ever been
there before you've seen the wheels
those are all actual mechanical parts
that actually spin and those are very
very costly to maintain sometimes they
break sometimes they cause people to win
and the casino doesn't like that because
of a flaw or something and so if you
ever go back now and you take a look at
those slot machines those are all
actually digital wheels they look very
very realistic but they are no longer
mechanical and so for those types of
slot machines their document could look
like this so their information would
hold not just the decommissioned date
let's say they've taken that old one out
put a new one in goes into the slot
machine graveyard but while it was in
service we have a maintenance log for
the different types of services that it
obtained as well as when that occurred
so again polymorphic just states that
for all of these different kinds of slot
machines and more all of those different
type of documents with different types
of fields and different types of
information according to the slot
machine that we're keeping track of can
exist
in harmony in the same collection
and that's it that's our data model so
let's take a look at it very quickly
we've applied the document versioning
pattern with both the players and with
the slot machines we have polymorphic
pattern applied particularly to the
slots because of all the different types
of slots there are and we have the
attribute pattern applied in particular
to the bonus structures for the slots
and you'll find that all of those
additional sub documents from the top
slots to the contact information the
membership information the participating
slots as well as the
the bonuses here those have all been
opted to be embedded because of the way
that we query them and this is what our
data model could look like now this is
what it could look like at this moment
but let's say our application changes
there's some new fancy i think there's a
new slot machine now which they're
trying to target to millennials where
you actually play video games and that's
how you play
i don't know how that's going to work i
don't know what those bonus structures
look like there's some of them or you
play tetris there's some of them where
you play um uh
um
i'm gonna
uh space invaders like they're trying to
really get millennial money the money
that we don't have and give it to the
casino but they're trying to find
another audience
and they're building those types of slot
machines so when those pieces of
information change or there's different
types of attributes for those types of
slot machines we can go through this
process again and maybe we find those
slot machines are the ones that are
doing the best and we change our data
model accordingly so that's the best
part about doing this type of work and
developing this type of data model is
that as your application evolves as the
pieces of information that you work with
changes as your workload changes you go
through these phases again and see if
they need to be done in order to give
you a better data model it's an
iterative process that goes along with
the application development process that
you may go through
and those are the three phases right
make sense of your workload to gather
everything there is to know about your
data
move into the phase two which is to map
out what relationships are there and
decide whether to link or to embed them
and then only if necessary apply design
patterns
so the last question what do we actually
model for and in most cases it's
actually
important to choose this early on but
you can also do this the second time
around and when you it comes to choosing
a data model for document databases
these are the two options is it
simplicity or is it performance
and there are a few things that we need
to take a look at
so
for your data model if you want to are
on the side of simplicity which is what
we usually encourage you'll want to take
a look at the size of your project
is it a small one is it an early stage
app is it an mvp is it something that
only you will be using or your team will
be using uh what is the size of your
team are you going to be the sole person
that's handling this application as well
as being the dba for it uh do you have a
smaller team or you may not have as much
dedicated time to put into this
what are the data sizes that you are
dealing with for your application are
you using shared resources do you not
have that much traffic what is your
expected skill do you have very very few
users or do you only have traffic that's
maybe like
you know a few hundred hundred requests
per hour uh some of the applications
that i've worked on in the past had that
type of skill yet some of the engineers
that we had wanted to prematurely
optimize for thousands of requests per
second i said whoa we don't need that
right now we only have this much based
on our production logs uh at the most
we're only ever going to get maybe like
500 or 600 requests per two or three
hours so when you have those types of
pieces of information from your first
phase
it's a good way for you to justify no we
need to actually add some more
changes because we need more performance
because we have this type of expected
traffic or you can say no we don't need
all of that complexity right now this is
what we're dealing with let's choose the
simpler data model
and of course it falls on the other side
of the spectrum if you do need to model
for performance so if your project is
much larger if you are a distributed
project
if you have a very very large team or
distributed teams you have more people
to be able to focus on these issues and
focus on continuously iterating that
data model if you have you know sizes
that are very very large so you are
already sharding your clusters and you
are on multiple regions and if your
expected scale is at that rate you're
dealing with thousands of requests per
second or you're a very right heavy
application then you can start to
consider yes performance is probably
something we should be modeling for
as always er on the side of simplicity
so because this is an iterative process
because we can do this over and over
again you always want to start out with
the most simple data model because
that's always the easiest one to build
on top of it's always the easiest one
for you to understand three months later
when you look at it and it's always the
the suggested route to go through start
simply build upon it only if you need it
to do that you would focus on the most
frequent operations so again those
phases are very important because
when you decide what you're going to
model for simplicity or performance you
can pick those pieces out so maybe you
have listed out the top 10 or 20
operations that you have for simplicity
focus on the most frequent ones focus on
the most important ones the ones that
your application can't live without
embed most things and then again only
use a pattern if it makes sense for the
most part the pattern that you would
probably most likely benefit from are
either the document versioning pattern
or the schema versioning pattern and
that's probably it that's good enough
for you
if you want a model for performance this
is where it gets a little bit more
tricky there's a little bit more work
involved you need to consider all of
those operations you want to make sure
you have that granular detail how many
writes per second how many reads per
second what is your traffic look like at
what time what causes traffic spikes etc
etc you want to embed and link as
necessary so when it comes to
performance you won't
most likely won't be able to get away
with just embedding everything
especially if you're dealing with a
large number of documents linking will
be necessary because embedding too much
information is also a bad thing
and then of course you want to use as
many patterns as necessary and as needed
so maybe you're not using all of them
right away but you build upon it as you
find that you need it so what most
people do is they they go somewhere in
the middle right actually they want both
because everybody wants everything they
want their cake and eat it too so you
fall right in the middle
and so in this case you go
most operations maybe the top five maybe
the top three you will want to embed and
link and then you'll only want to use a
few patterns but then continuously add
more patterns if you find that your
current application doesn't meet some
sort of performance threshold that you
have set
for yourself
and with that i want to say salamat that
means thank you in tagalog i hope you
learned something about data modeling
maybe more about slot machines
i am very happy to answer any questions
that i can answer thank you so much
yeah thank you
yes
if i understand your question correctly
can the application
determine which version of the document
to use
okay
sure
yes so depending on the document
database that you use
my background is in
ex mongodb but mongodb and i'm sure
documentdb and cosmos db have something
similar
you can use either a a trigger or you
can use some right rules to enforce that
schema so there is schema validation
that is applicable to your collections
so in that case let's say floor manager
you want to make sure that it always has
it i mean it will exist
if you manually overwrite it if you
insert a document without one it's going
to be possible but if you want to make
sure from the application that it goes
through that schema validation there are
rules that you can apply that says even
though it can exist you don't want it to
so there are rules you can apply with
schema validation
yes
so one way that this has been
implemented
is to do it based on the
microservice itself so whatever the
microservice needs whatever information
that particular piece needs that's what
you would i guess use to guide which
parts you embed uh and so it won't be as
straightforwardly cut as this this isn't
a typical application right uh either
monolithic application or something
that's not so distributed but uh that
goal post would move to instead of that
particular entity or what you query for
you now embed the things that would be
needed by that particular service
uh repeat one more time
okay
um if i understand your question
correctly there would be the application
of both the document versioning pattern
so you could have both pieces or both
versions of that exist and then it would
be up to your application to query the
correct collection
for the shared objects there is an
option to do something called a union
all or an out where let's say the pieces
that are shared they change very uh very
very often
if you are changing the base collections
so let's say they're shared pieces of
information from two collections and
that merge together is what's shared
across certain different pieces what you
can do is use an aggregation pipeline to
kind of collect that information and
then send it outward so you can
replicate or you can update those models
and update the collection uh as
necessary but
one way to do it is to get the
aggregation pipeline use some sort of
identifier to get the version that you
need and then aggregate that information
to be sent off to what is being shared i
don't know if that answers your question
i answered it in the way that i think
oh okay um in that case to know where so
with the duplication of information if
you do embed it there are database
triggers that you can use so let's say
you are updating the the parent document
right you are you are updating the
casino and for the uh owner information
that we had which we had embedded if we
are updating that particular owner
document there can be a trigger that
looks for anywhere that it has been
embedded uh
this in this case you would have to use
some sort of identifier to know where it
has been embedded and then it can do a
cascading trigger to all of the
documents to update accordingly every
time that parent document has been
updated so in that way that's one way to
do it to kind of keep track of all the
places you may have embedded and make
sure it does
update accordingly when you when you
change it
yes
is
yes so the the guideline there is if
most of your documents or even some of
your documents have to be switched over
into a linking manner it's best to
actually change all the documents to
fall in that format that way you don't
have two different uh versions of that
so you don't want to reach that that's
an excellent point most documents
mongodb for example has a 16 megabyte
limit per document so if you start
reaching that limit or you're even
getting anywhere close to that that's
also another guideline to say maybe you
shouldn't be embedding this is already
pretty large you want to probably break
it up and start linking those pieces of
information so yeah that is a good
guideline to just say if you're reaching
that limit or if you find that you have
a few that you even need to change it's
better to have
even though it's possible to have both
versions exist
when working with it in an application
it's much easier for you to deal with if
you just change everything to the
linking format for that document
any other questions if you think of one
i'll be around for a moment you can come
up here as well
alright thank you so much
you